okay so that's that's all they wanted
for part one just find that area and
then they give us a new piece of fishing
we are taller this is part two now we
are told that looks this should be
ovation yep we are told that DV DT
equals just pause for a second year
right what does this statement say I
this is what we love about ballet so it
boils everything's now incredibly to see
these okay number one because I don't
actually they said they haven't said K
is a positive number but it's kind of
its kind of implied the command pre
owned by the side here if k1 negative i
might as well just not put a bigger
sandal but this is the change in volume
right this is how the water content is
changing yeah it should be decreasing
because the thing is evaporating yeah
but not only is it decreasing its
decreasing in a particular way it's
decreasing as a multiple or in
proportion to what the surface area is
right so you can see k is a constant I
think they send some question as a gets
smaller dvf dt gets smaller does that
make sense more area means faster
evaporation less area smaller rubbish
that's like sayin because like every
time yeah yeah I'm just trying to make
sure i interpret like what this means
because this is kind of a link it's an
exponential growth of decay because
you're going to see examples that are in
a not quite this fall but in a very
similar form where there's a derivative
that is some multiple that is some
proportionality to some other closed
fists some other variable rather it's
important in the question so in this
case the variable that really matters is
surface area and is that gets smaller
evaporation can get slower okay so I'm
going to take this down and have a look
at what they want us to do show that the
rate at which the depth of the water
changes is negative k huh so what I'm
looking at is this thing here this
distance and I want to look at how
that's getting what should be getting
smaller and smaller smaller right now if
I wanted to I could introduce a new
very well i suppose and call this right
I've give it a name like Sadie for depth
right I could do that but I already have
a variable in my question that's
equivalent to this right is as this is
getting smaller you can see that H which
is right above it is getting bigger
right so all I really need is an
expression for how H is changing over
time what do I call that expression th
on TT very good so I want this but use
you all the knowledge we have a Fraser
change in how to convert from like these
are the rates that I know to this rate
that I don't know how am I going to get
ghod team will use I'm gonna breach anal
into play so clearly i'm going to need
addy a chore the top and the dt on the
bottom and then you look at you say I'll
ok I had to be on duty so that must be
this guy right and if it's there I'm
going to need to cancel so I'm going to
need that here does that make sense so
I'm writing this I'm actually not ready
to evaluate this year because I don't
know what this is but at least this
statement tells me oh now I know what I
need to learn out that's why um this was
about right because this is V as a
function of H write V is a [ __ ]
nation so I can workout DVD H off of
this line okay in fact I'm going to be a
bit sneaky I'm going to work it out off
this life can you tell me what DV on D H
is going to be okay so there's a
constant of sleep out at the front
and your magic the third out right well
I can put it back in now because these
are both divisible by three so I'm gonna
have pie that looks familiar okay so so
now now I'm ready to actually do this
yeah so I know what our DV o th is so
therefore dho DV is the reciprocal so
i'm going to write that okay and they
just told me what dbl duty was I'm
actually going to I don't to skip this
step it's minus ka but in not the
previous page path the previous part i
worked out what a was right so this is
what over it is pretty minus K times and
here comes my area expression okay so
this is x pi 16 points and sweat now
remember having a look at this question
it's a show question okay so i don't
want to skip anything about i think it's
fair to cancel pies okay but to make
this really really clear you can see
that these two are backwards yes these
two backwards so I'm going to use that
by this side and bring it inside okay so
this leaves me of k times x squared
minus 16 on h squared minus 16 I don't
skip that my know it seemed to be
trivial but have you put that minus sign
in now I cancel cancel so therefore I
get this okay pause we always say you
get to the end of like a known amount of
work in that you think have I answered
the question I haven't answered the
question have I why not why not okay so
the first thing is here you have a
slight moment of panic where you're like
wait I didn't 1k I want a negative K but
that's all right in fact that's kind of
what we expected because remember we're
not talking like dho dt h is not the
depth of the panel h is the distance
above the puddle that distance should be
getting bigger which is why the puddle
is getting smaller so you want to just
have a little
sentence here right you should say um
since K is increasing right this is
positive sorry h yes so edges H is
increasing at a rate of cake right I
haven't even given the water a name so
I'm just going to call it the depth of
the product right so you've got two
quantities that increase and decrease
exactly according to an eye because
they're different they're adjacent parts
of it the definitely water is decreasing
or this is a bit funny I don't like the
way that they've said is necessarily I
think it makes more sense to say
decreasing at a rate of K but they've
given us changes at a rate of negative K
because the word changes it doesn't have
like a sign sort of associated with it
where is increasing a distressing do so
i'm just going to use the language that
they have because that's resolved so the
depth of the water is changing at a rate
of minus ok all right and I didn't even
have units on k yet that's cuz I'm going
to get them in the last part of the
question okay so by the way that's
that's really important that's that's
like a buck right there later y'all
interpret that and then we'll get this
out of it alternatively where should you
could have done is you could have
introduced another variable and then
that variable is going to have a
negative attached to it which is what
you've wanted the first place but I kind
of like using less variables rather than
war okay